LET NOT YOUR HEART BE >> Laura:
WE HAVE A LOT TO GET TO TONIGHT.
I AM LAURA INGRAHAM AND THIS IS
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" FROM
WASHINGTON OUT OF CHICAGO AND
ACCORDING TO THE POLICE, 14
PEOPLE WERE INJURED.
MOST OF THEM SHOT NEAR A FUNERAL
HOME IN A COMMUNITY CALLED
AUBURN GRESHAM.
AND A PRESS CONFERENCE A SHORT
TIME AGO THE POLICE SAID THERE
WAS A PLANNED AMBUSH OUTSIDE OF
THE FUNERAL HOME WHERE MEMORIAL
SERVICE IS GOING ON INSIDE FOR A
HOMICIDE VICTIM.
AT THE END OF LAST WEEK IN
CHICAGO, RENDERS UP 51%,
SHOOTINGS 40 4047% AND THE
STAGGERING NUMBERS,
MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT PRESIDED
OVER A CITY THAT HAS TURNED INTO
THE WILD WEST.
NOW LET ME MAKE THIS AS CLEAR AS
I CAN MAKE IT TONIGHT.
IT IS OPEN SEASON ON THE
CITIZENS OF CHICAGO AND THE
MAYOR CANNOT BE BOTHERED TO
ACCEPT REAL FEDERAL HELP.
YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE OF HER SEETHING HATRED
FOR DONALD TRUMP.
THAT IS OUTWEIGHING HER CONCERN
FOR THE CITIZENS THAT SHE IS
SUPPOSED TO BE SERVING.
NOW, THE HEAD OF THE CHICAGO
FRATERNAL ORDER OF POLICE WAS
HERE TONIGHT TO ACT TO
MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT’S REFUSAL
TO ACCEPT HELP BUT INSTEAD WILL
REACT TO THE STORY.
JOHN JOINS ME NOW EXCLUSIVELY,
JOHN, ARE YOU AS UNHINGED AS
MAYOR LIGHTFOOT SAYS YOU ARE?
SEE, SHE IS PUTTING IT ON YOU.
THAT IS WHAT SHE IS DOING.
PUTTING IT ON YOU.
MAYBE IT IS FOX OR TRUMP,
EVERYONE BUT LOOKING IN THE
MIRROR AND ALSO AT THE
CRIMINALS.
>> GOOD EVENING, LAURA, THANKS
FOR HAVING ME.
FIRST OF ALL, THE MAYOR LIKES TO
USE THE WORD UNHINGED BUT THE
IRONIC PART OF THE MAYOR BECAME
UNHINGED.
I WISH I COULD SHOW YOU THE TEXT
MESSAGES OVER THE WEEKEND AS
SOON AS SHE FOUND OUT I SENT A
REQUEST TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SHE WAS THE ONE WHO TOTALLY
BECAME UNHINGED, UNPROFESSIONAL,
CHILDISH AND REALLY PATHETIC FOR
THE LEADER OF THE CITY.
>> Laura: WELL, RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE CARNAGE AS FAR AS I CAN
SEE.
WE DON’T KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN
AND WE DON’T HAVE DEPTH OF THE
INJURIES BUT IT LOOKED PRETTY
WILD ON THE SCENE THAT WAS
SHOWN.
THIS WAS OUTSIDE OF A FUNERAL
HOME SO IF YOU ARE GOING TO
SHOOT OUTSIDE OF A FUNERAL HOME
SOME SIGNAGE ABOUT THE FUNERAL
THEY HAD ON THE STREET AND
APPARENTLY IT WAS SOME POLICE
PRESENCE SOMEWHERE ON THE SCENE.
YOU’VE GOTTEN REALLY BOLD,
HAVEN’T YOU, JOHN?
YOU ARE PRETTY BOLD AS A
CRIMINAL AND YOU’RE NOT WORRIED.
>> LIKE SHAUN’S GUEST SAID, THE
BOLD IS THERE BECAUSE THERE IS
NO CONSEQUENCES.
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM IN
COOK COUNTY HAS BROKEN ALL THE
WAY FROM THE PRESIDENT TO KIM
FOX, THE PROSECUTOR TO THE
SHERIFF, TIM OPENS THE CHIEF
JUDGE PIER THEY HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT REAL JUSTICES.
THAT IS BASICALLY THE BLOODBATH
IN THE STREET AS A RESULT.
>> Laura: LORI LIGHTFOOT SAID
BRING PEOPLE INTO THIS BACK AND
FORTH TO PUT IT POLITELY, JOHN,
BETWEEN YOU AND LIGHTFOOT.
THIS IS WHAT SHE SAID.
EVERYONE WATCH.
>> WE’VE GOT TO UNHINGED THE
LEADERS OF THE FRATERNAL ORDER
OF POLICE WHO IS CRAZY AND IN
TRYING TO GET ATTENTION.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS ROAD FOR US
TO GO DOWN.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE PEOPLE
THAT DON’T KNOW WHERE STREETS
ENGAGING IN CLEARLY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL CONDUCT OF
OPERATING AT WILL IN OUR CITIES.
THAT IS CHAOS.
THAT IS LAWLESSNESS.
>> Laura: THAT IS CHAOS.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING TONIGHT
WASN’T CHAOS, BUT YOU WANTING
FEDERAL HELP AND ACTUAL
ASSISTANCE IS CHAOS?
THIS WOMAN DOESN’T KNOW HER OWN
CITY, OKAY?
IT IS A TRAVESTY.
I THOUGHT I WAS MAD ABOUT OTHER
THINGS TONIGHT GIVEN WHAT IS
GOING ON IN THE COUNTRY, BUT
THIS IS AN OUTRAGE.
THE GREAT AMERICAN CITIES BEING
SERVED BY HER, A RADICAL, AND
TALK HER OUT OF OFFICE, JOHN, GO
AHEAD APPEAR IT’S BECAUSE SHE IS
REALLY RUNNING THE TITANIC INTO
AN ICEBERG INTENTIONALLY.
66 ROUNDS AND PEOPLE SHOT
TONIGHT AT A FUNERAL WHERE THE
POLICE OBVIOUSLY SPECIAL
ATTENTION BECAUSE OF THE GANG
VICTIM THAT WAS ALREADY BEING
WAKED AT THE FUNERAL HOME.
THE IRONY ABOUT HER NOT KNOWING
THE CITY STREETS AND THE FEDERAL
OFFICERS, SHE JUST END THIS
ISN’T A KNOCK ON THE
SUPERINTENDENT BECAUSE I LIKE
THE SUPERINTENDENT BUT SHE HIRED
AN OUTSIDER THAT DIDN’T KNOW THE
CITY, DIDN’T KNOW THE STREETS.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE?
AGAIN, SHE HAS A BIG HYPOCRITE.
SHE HAS A NAPOLEON COMPLEX AND
IF YOU DON’T AGREE WITH HER,
HEAVEN FORBID.
>> Laura: THE FUNERAL
ATTENDEES, I UNDERSTAND, RETURN
FIRE ON THE VEHICLE.
SO THESE WERE ALL GANG BANGERS,
RIGHT?
IF YOU HAD TO SUM IT UP FOR US,
THE CONJECTURE OF THIS WE NEED
TO KNOW MORE, BUT PEOPLE ARE
FIRING ON EACH OTHER.
THIS IS PART OF THE WILD WEST.
THIS IS A KILLING FIELD IN
CHICAGO.
WE ARE COMPLAINING ABOUT TRUMP,
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
TALK ABOUT BLAME SHIFTING
PUTTING IT ON YOU AND THE
FRATERNAL ORDER OF POLICE OR THE
COPS ON THE BEACH?
WHAT ARE THE HECK THE COP
SUPPOSED TO DO WITH NO SUPPORT
FROM CITY HALL?
WERE THEY SUPPOSED TO DO?
>> YOU HIGHLIGHTED OBVIOUSLY THE
SHOOTINGS AND MURDERS, BUT YOU
KNOW SUPERINTENDENT BROWN
BASICALLY SAID YESTERDAY THAT
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT HAS
RECOVERED 5400 GUNS SO FOR THE
SHEER OFF OF THE STREETS OF
CHICAGO.
NOW, AS HE PROPERLY HIGHLIGHTED,
THAT IS 54 DEADLY ENCOUNTERS,
5400 DEADLY ENCOUNTERS THE MEN
AND WOMEN OF THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT HAVE DEALT WITH OVER
THE FIRST SIX MONTHS OF THIS
YEAR AND NOT A SINGLE PERSON I
SHOULDN’T SAY NOT A SINGLE
PERSON BUT I THINK ONLY THREE
SHOOTINGS THAT RESULTED IN
DEATHS.
BUT MY POINT IS HOW MANY MORE
GUNS OR HOW MANY MORE MURDERS
WOULD OCCUR IF THE GUNS WERE NOT
TAKEN OFF THE STREET.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, THERE IS A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARRESTED WITH THOSE
GUNS THAT WERE IMMEDIATELY LEFT
OUT ON THE STREET AGAIN AND IT
GOES BACK TO KIM FOX AND THE
BROKEN COUNTY JAIL SYSTEM.
>> Laura: THIS IS A REVOLVING
DOOR OF SO-CALLED CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM.
SOMEONE IS ARRESTED ON A MONDAY.
THEY ARE RELEASED ON TUESDAY
MORNING.
THEY GET THEIR CRIMINAL
DEFENDER, PUBLIC DEFENDER, AND
WE ARE CRYING ABOUT HOW UNFAIR
THE SYSTEM IS.
AND I JUST WANT -- IF EVERYONE
IS JOINING US TONIGHT, THERE WAS
A DISTURBING SCENE IN CHICAGO A
FEW HOURS AGO AT A FUNERAL.
WE HAD 14 PEOPLE SHOT.
MANY IN THE HOSPITAL.
PEOPLE WERE RETURNING FIRE FROM
THE FUNERAL TO THE CARS THAT
WERE GOING OFF IN DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS AND APPARENTLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SHOOTING
COMING FROM MULTIPLE DIRECTIONS.
THE REPORTS WE ARE GETTING
TONIGHT, JOHN, AND AT THE SAME
TIME THIS IS HAPPENING TONIGHT,
WE HAVE UTTER LAWLESSNESS IN
ANOTHER GREAT AMERICAN CITY OF
PORTLAND, OREGON.
AND WE HAVE PEOPLE IN PORTLAND,
OREGON, WHO ARE TELLING THE
MEDIA NOT TO COVER IT BECAUSE
THAT TELLS A VERY DISTORTED
STORY.
PEOPLE ARE COVERING IT BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO HURT PEOPLE
POLITICALLY.
NO, WE WANT TO COVER IT BECAUSE
WE WANT TO SAVE LIVES, PROPERTY
AND LIVELIHOOD.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF AOC AND
AGAIN GET THEIR WAY WITH BIDEN
AND THE WHOLE CROWD AND DEFUND
THE POLICE?
THIS IS DEFINED AND DISMANTLED
THE POLICE MOVEMENTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, JOHN.
HIS TONIGHT’S SCENE GOING TO BE
REPEATED ACROSS URBAN AMERICAN?
I DON’T KNOW ABOUT RIB IN
AMERICA BUT CHICAGO IS UNIQUE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I’VE SAID IT TIME AND TIME AGAIN
APPROXIMATELY NEW YORK IS 2.5 2.
THE SIZE BUT 30% MORE MURDERS
THAN THE WHOLE CITY OF NEW YORK.
LET THAT SINK IN.
THERE WAS A MINDLESS COMEAU
LAWLESS MINDLESS SET IN THE CITY
WHERE THEY JUST DO WHATEVER THEY
WANT BECAUSE NO REPERCUSSION.
THERE WAS NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS IS PIGGYBACKING ON FRIDAY
NIGHTS SCENE WHERE A LARGE GROUP
OF OFFICERS TRYING TO PROTECT
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS DAY STATUE
BEING PULLED DOWN AND 52
OFFICERS WERE INJURED AND THAT
MELEE.
THEY WANT TO PRETEND THIS WAS A
HANDFUL OF ANARCHISTS THAT
EMBEDDED THEMSELVES IN THE
PROTEST.
THE PROTESTERS KNEW THAT THIS
WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
THEY PROTECTED THESE PEOPLE
UNTIL THEY WENT DOWN.
WE TALK ABOUT ACCOUNT THE LAST
WEEK AND JUST THIS POINT COME
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THEY CRY THAT POLICE OFFICERS
DON’T SPEAK UP, THEY PROTECT BAD
BEHAVIOR BUT WHAT ABOUT ALL THE
GOOD PROTESTERS WHO STOOD THERE
AND WATCH THE ANARCHIST RURAL
FIREWORKS, FROZEN WATER, BRICKS
AT OFFICERS AND DID NOTHING?
THEY DID NOTHING.
>> Laura: I’M TIRED OF THE LIE
THEY ARE OFFERING TO GOOD
PROTESTERS.
YOU SHOULDN’T BE THROWING STUFF
AT POLICE WERE STANDING BY
PEOPLE WHO ARE THROWING STUFF AT
THE POLICE COME OKAY?
SHOULDN’T BE PULLING DOWN
STATUES, IT IS NOT YOUR
PROPERTY.
IF YOU WANT TO TAKE DOWN A
STATUE GO THE LEGAL WAY AMP
PETITION ALDERMAN BUT DON’T PULL
ROPES AND PULL DOWN STATUES.